こんにちははじめしてそうです皆さんスノーというアプリご存知でしょうか
あのねすげー流行低下も大流行しておりますご今日ですね1階ですねその上借りて行っ
たんですよ
カシャってこう犬の犬八尾北昔ツイッターで潰れたらすっげーでツイートされました
うふなんかねすごいあの可愛く撮れるんですよねちょっとやってみるよとりあえず
イケメンだなぁハイテクでこちらが画面になっております基本的にはそんな変わらない
んですけどもこれでいきますよ
講座等色々デコできるんですよまあでたこれが出ましたこれですこれおねえちゃんきゃ
んですわ
カーリー
自分でか言ったらなんかヤバイって言うならこれから出て自分が頭にあって負担ぷが出
てくると言う
めっちゃちょっと一枚撮ってみましょう
このさ自撮りしてる時の自分の顔嫌なんですよね上目遣いで
きたじゃないですか罰濃いでしょこういう感じですねとするのは写真撮るだけじゃなく
ておくれます
かわいい絶対なんかとってやら大きてきて来た来たん
愛という感じですね実はスノーはですねその写真とかの動画を撮るだけじゃなくて
メッセージのやり取りがすることができますが誤ってきた
ゆぅーという感じなんですけども郊外ちょっとこのスノー使っていろんな子をとってみ
ましょうというシンプルな動画でございますめちゃくちゃ面白いって言ってかほんとに
ちょっと六もめちゃくちゃやってみるでしょ
まあいいなぁこれや多分一番
人気なのかなこんなのもありますし歯科
うーんなんか完全にオネエだな
くま
あっ熊川いいなこれ
明日が出るのね口を開けて舌がでるん
どことなくアバンティーズの映司くんに似てますねワーコレだけネタ
まあこれかわいいこいつまたぞとに写真7
こういう写真がですね twitter ですごい流行ってるですよね
ああ可愛い俺さん前
自撮り好きじゃないんですよジュリー好きじゃないボケでもコンテンツもするってこと
はすごい強
はかわいい
かわいいが c 送ってあげようっていう感じですね送り合うっていう楽しさもあり
ます
へっ
寒天3巻最初
すごいもの寿司だったんだあっちの村にす
すごいものと縛ったんだはいですねこのようにするのを使えば様々な顔で遊ぶことが
できます
はい的でここからでございますスタンプとかもう遅いんですけどもう僕はこので画像を
使うのが一番面白いと思っておりますさあさあが買ってきたぞ
なかなかいいメンツじゃないかじゃあまずはですね
例の富と1それか
対してみましょうかこのマナーと3つの方ががったりすると
後ろとめちゃくちゃやんけどっちかな
を何か欲しいってのなにこれでちょっと待ってね違う
俺はまあ俺は俺なんだすごい自分の合体しても自分のままですねあかりのとミット
めがけしますこ
ああ
これは結構普通に合体できたねロマンと2店です
すごー
こんなになるんですよじゃあ次三男さんですごめんなさい三田3カップに酔っちゃって
はいよーそれなーから退いていくののさんだなぁ
ん
アーカード起こすべくなどするはいという感じですね
スタンプ以外にもですね自分が持っている顔の写真とか他の人の顔写真とかで合成さ
せることもできます face コピーを使えば多分何人かが入るとみんなです同じ顔
を共有できるという9編までたぶん僕一人だとできないんですけどみんなでやると
とても面白いと思います
ピーッ
はずへ配置受けてくださったでしょうか角をいう感じですね
もうこんないかついお兄さんでもあっという間ににゃんことになります
かわいい俺じゃあ自分で恥ずかしいとかを払おう
あああ
ああああああ
ですよ空いてるでこんな感じでかわいい自分が取れたりしますその気になって仕方が
ねえ
ぜひ皆さん州の可愛いんでやってみてくださいじゃあな
4日
おっ
par
ん
me
愛と輝度高入れ替える相手に来てくれたのでちょっとかを入れ替えてみましょう
スパああああああ
俺の旅家と this player
愛してるくれたを変えるとこんな風になってしまいます
目ですねっとボタンを長押しすると動画が撮れます
私だ
そういうどうぞ取れるんですけども撮った動画は誰かに送ることができます
不不不不不不不不不